ça va tout à fait dans le sens des
recommandations internationales de l'
oms qui ont été édictées au début de la
pandémie de tester l'ensemble donc des
patients symptomatiques la stratégie de
la france était un peu plus restreinte
au début était certainement dictée par
les capacités donc analytique qui était
un petit peu limité en france au début
de la pandémie qui ont évolué très
rapidement puisqu'il faut savoir que
depuis trois semaines on a multiplié
effectivement nos capacités donc de
réalisation de tests naso pharyngé par
pcr par cinq
donc c'est un très bel effort de
mobilisation des laboratoires de
biologie médicale et on est prêt même
aller encore plus loin pour relever donc
le défi d'ici le 11 mai pouvoir tester
l'ensemble des français qui présentent
des symptômes